[Applaudissements]
s'investir à fond dans une passion
t'es fatigant non
on a que 24 heures dans une journée
entre les cours les potes le sommeil
il y a plus la place pour grand chose
c'est frustrant d'avoir si peu de temps
pour les passions il faudrait un truc
pour avoir plus de 24 heures dans une
journée ou alors savoir les utiliser
pleinement
essayez de vous rappeler d'un moment de
votre vie lors duquel vous vous êtes
senti pleinement aligné
vous avez ressenti que vous étiez à
votre juste place
fermez les yeux
allez-y ferme les yeux
et remémorez vous cette sensation
revoyez vous étiez avec qui est-ce que
vous faisiez comment vous vous sentiez
dans votre corps dans votre esprit
que vous pouvez ouvrir les yeux
vous l'avez peut-être senti
c'est la force de la passion elle
modifie complètement notre rapport au
temps et allergie les deux seules
véritables ressources
vivre aligné avec ses valeurs avec ses
croyances
c'est la source d'une force immense
bonjour je m'appelle Sacha Bourguet et
j'ai choisi la 3 ans que je vivrai pour
améliorer le monde autour de moi si le
contact avec la mort avec la maladie qui
a été mon étincelle
puis des amis qui s'engagés déjà ont
donné des conseils et m'ont montré leur
lutte pour alimenter la flamme et
démarrer la locomotive de mon engagement
vous savez j'étais déjà tombé amoureux
de toi j'avais donc compris l'effet d'un
corps rempli d'endorphines dans chaque
centilitre de sang le forêt
puis j'avais fait face à la misère en
participant à des associations venant
aide aux personnes aux grandes
difficultés sociales
je m'étais rappelé ma chance
et j'avais voulu donner la possibilité à
tout le monde de se remplir aussi un peu
d'endorphines
vous savez
je crois profondément que nous avons des
leçons à tirer de chaque expérience
même si elles ne sont pas toutes
confortables
et je vois en particulier trois contacts
essentiels à expérimenter 3 étincelles
tout d'abord le contact avec l'amour
et je ne parle pas que de l'amour qu'on
peut avoir avec son copain ou sa copine
pour ma part j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
une mère très aimante qui m'a apporté
tout l'amour dont un enfant peut rêver
c'est pour comprendre l'objectif avoir
une vision claire de ce que l'on veut
apporter au monde
ensuite le contact avec la misère un peu
moins confortable
pour se rappeler de la chance que l'on a
et du devoir qui en découle le devoir de
donner la chance à chaque être humain de
vivre l'amour
enfin il me semble essentiel
d'expérimenter le contact avec la mort
pour se rappeler que notre temps est
précieux et que nous avons un devoir
envers nous-mêmes de l'utiliser au mieux
l'utiliser au mieux
c'est facile à dire
c'est une question assez complexe
comment utiliser son temps
et bien c'est un cheminant vers la
réponse à cette question que j'ai mis le
doigt sur l'une de mes passions qui
surpasse les autres
laissez-moi vous raconter
ascension
c'est une association étudiante que j'ai
fondée il y a environ un an visant à
créer un spectacle avec les sans-abris à
Compiègne ma ville étudiante leur
permettre de créer du lien social de se
redécouvrir capable de progresser et de
réussir au sein d'un groupe bienveillant
heure de chaque atelier d'ascension nous
rendons accessible des produits
d'hygiène et des vêtements
nous développons des compétences du
spectacle et nous partageons un repas
tous ensemble
mercredi 6 avril 2022
c'était le deuxième atelier d'ascension
avec une autre membre de l'association
nous avons fait un tour en ville pour
aller inviter des sans-abri et nous
avons commencé dans un quartier un peu
excentré on est sans abri très gentille
creusez la semaine précédente nous avait
donné rendez-vous
Delphine
nous avons fait le chemin avec elle
beaucoup discuter sur ce chemin on a
commencé prudemment puis fait quelques
blagues
elle ne rendait tout l'amour qu'on
essayait de lui donner maladroitement
souriante et pleine d'énergie
d'assurance
c'était magique
elle aussi un peu ouverte à nous sur ce
trajet quelques peines et épreuves en
durcissant le cœur
on a creusé d'autres sans-abriques en
rejoint le groupe puis nous sommes
arrivés sur place d'autres étudiants de
l'association avaient déjà amené 400
abris
je suis arrivé avec la cuisine que
j'avais faite pour l'occasion et on a
passé une bonne heure à discuter et si
quelque part de jonglage chanté autour
de la guitare manger rire
et sans abri reporter petit à petit
avec le sourire
leur donner rendez-vous prochaine
atelier pour la suite
à la fin il ne reste plus que Delphine
on danse tous ensemble elle nous apprend
quelque part on discute encore
et alors qu'elle ne remercie
quelques normes s'échappe de ses yeux
petits
elle pleure
mais surtout elle sourit
elle nous dit qu'elle n'avait pas
ressenti une telle chaleur humaine
depuis longtemps
ses yeux brillent
créer
la joie
je me suis senti pleinement aligné ce
jour-là
mais valeurs et mes actes en plein homme
et
la passion appelle à l'action
fermez les yeux à nouveau
et imaginez-vous visualisez vous en
train de vivre une passion
ressentez les sensations qu'elle vous
procure votre perception de votre
environnement qui est un petit peu
différente votre perception de votre
corps qui change un peu votre état de
concentration ou de relâchement ou les
deux en même temps
ok vous pouvez ouvrir les yeux
vous l'avez sûrement déjà senti
peut-être même maintenant le visualisant
lorsque vous agissez aligner passionné
de nouvelles ressources s'ouvrent en
vous
vous savez que vous avancez dans la
bonne direction et par conséquent les
perturbations deviennent secondaires
la peur notamment et cachée par la
lumière de l'étoile que vous poursuivez
chaque pas dans la bonne direction
et une réussite
ça paraît merveilleux
les nouvelles ressources qui s'ouvrent à
nous la réussite c'est plutôt facile de
vivre aligné alors non
est-ce qu'il y a des parents dans la
salle ce soir
alors c'est facile il y avait des
enfants
lorsqu'on vit aligner on apprend à vivre
très intensement à flamboyer voyez un
train sur ses rails c'est l'ensemble
vers son étoile
il peut être très rapide
mais la vitesse
c'est dangereux
la flamme de la passion qu'il alimente
ce train
reste
une flamme
il y a tout de même quelques écueils
l'épuisement
la culpabilité
la sueur focalisation
de mon parcours d'engagement il y a eu
un point de basculement il y a environ
un an
j'avais expérimenté quelques techniques
d'optimisation du temps j'avais donc
confiance en mes capacités
alors au cours du même semestre
j'ai repris la présidence de deux
grosses associations
j'ai finalisé le lancement de deux
autres associations que j'avais initiées
au semestre précédent de ascension
j'ai préparé avec mon équipe scout un
procédé d'éducation en Slovénie
et j'ai débuté un mandat des lieux
mince il est minuit et demi il me reste
14 mails à envoyer
sur côté
et les nuits blanches qui s'accumulent
l'épuisement
je passe 60 heures par semaine à me
donner corps pour améliorer le monde il
y a toujours tellement de gens qui
souffrent je devrais faire plus je
devrais faire mieux
chaque fois que je passais devant un
sans-abri dans la rue sans avoir le
temps de m'arrêter
la culpabilité
allô les gars allez au bar ce soir j'ai
pas trop le temps une soirée
ça fait trois semaines qu'on s'est pas
vu
je peux proposer vendredi entre 13h et
13h20
des moments essentiels qui passent
finalement la trappe
la surfocalisation
alors
comment se libérer de ces trois chaînes
douloureuses
et bien
j'ai trouvé deux clés qui ouvrent cette
recherche
la première s'appelle faire de mon mieux
je fais de mon mieux je peux être fier
de moi pour ça
je ne pourrais pas faire plus à
l'instant T faire plus n'est pas en mon
pouvoir
et grandir nous a bien appris qu'il faut
savoir renoncer à ce qui ne dépend pas
de notre volonté
donc la culpabilité perd son sens
la deuxième clé
je me connais la conscience je sais que
mon corps comme mon esprit ont besoin de
l'équilibre entre effort détente et
repos
mais au-delà de sa voix
je le ressens
je suis allé coude de mon corps et le
repos que je prends alors me préserve de
l'épuisement et je vois mes amis car
j'ai conscience de mon besoin lien
social mais car je les aime
je fais de mon mieux
je me connais je m'écoute
en évitant ses écueils épuisement la
culpabilité la surfocalisation
donc en utilisant ces deux clés
je fais de mon mieux je me connais
vous pourrez bien vivre aligner
et lorsque vous vivez bien aligné
vous êtes comme un train bien monté sur
ses rails il avance sans usure avec un
bon rendement filant à une vitesse
élevée et contrôlée
de même
vous êtes épanoui et efficace
alors
dans un monde idéal
on aurait 25 heures par jour
26 heures
30 heures 4 heures
si tu vis aligné avec tes valeurs
tu as le temps
24 heures et la bonne durée
rappelle-toi tu fais ton mieux alors
sois fier de toi pour ça
tu te connais tu vis avec satisfaction
et moments de détente de repos et
d'efforts
bien sûr tout le temps n'est pas infini
mais tu peux accomplir en 24 heures bien
plus que ce que tu n'imagines pour
l'instant
alors désormais
chaque fois que tu te diras
non
j'aurais pas le temps cette semaine
j'aurais pas le temps ce mois-ci
j'aurais pas le temps ce semestre
j'aurais pas le temps cette année
prends le contrôle de la petite voix
dans ta tête
et dis-toi à ton
cette activité
elle correspond vraiment à mes valeurs
je pense que
je me sentirai pleinement aligné
je me sentirai à ma place
alors je vais le faire
peut-être que je vais faire quelques
sacrifices au début le temps d'adapter
mon planning
je trouverai des méthodes pour optimiser
mon temps et mon énergie
j'en ai vraiment envie
alors je vais le faire
merci
[Applaudissements]